foreign
what am I looking at just look what am I
looking at for novice yes yes you are
you know his camera angle it's like
seeing a lens flare and it's like I know
who that is
good yeah well Dayton we have something
to say to you buddy guy who I know who
now watches the videos
um here's the thing
did you know and this is now verifiable
and we could verify this that you know
Dayton hypernova when he used to go to
high school
most days will go dressed as Captain
Jack Sparrow and stay in cut in in state
I swear to God this is true in staying
character so much so that the other kids
just started calling him jack because
they didn't know his real name oh my God
I swear to God
that's pretty embarrassing
also and of course this is just through
the ether who knows was caught maybe a
couple times on the phone saying I know
he doesn't really hit me but perception
is what matters
weird right it's a weird thing to say
did you know Dayton used to have a hot
girlfriend
yeah you told me about this and after
this hot girlfriend broke up with him
um he then later accused her of beating
of bullying him because he would wear
dresses the problem is he didn't start
wearing dresses until a couple years
after they broke up
um
and oh God there's so much okay anyway
that's just a little bit for now uh that
being said I will tell you this that we
are work we are working really hard to
get a GoFundMe for Jerry Dayton's uh dad
that is hopefully soon we'll have an
answer on that okay
now this is him filming of course
they're downstairs because his dad has
cancer and can't walk upstairs
here you go
show me a hundred dollars
did you know that when Dayton lived
without those roommates that uh that
apparently kicked them out rumor has it
that he still kept going back
every week go back to the parents house
to do laundry so they could still pay
him I'll go back there I thought you
might go back when he was kicked yeah
yeah I only wanted us hundred bucks a
week
so I'm recording this to my mom talking
my phone downstairs did you know
Dayton's an alcoholic
I'm shocked
to a neighbor here's a fun one you know
how Dayton's always complaining about
his uh his um
um what's the skin disease is um
psoriasis yeah psoriasis so he's always
complaining about it apparently there is
a medicine that is insurance covers that
would actually get rid of it it's an
injection that would get rid of it like
it works like 99 of the cases he doesn't
like that one he likes a different one
because he read online because he likes
it better the other one doesn't work as
well and the other one's not covered by
insurance so he makes his parents pay
for the one that's not covered by
Insurance even though there's one that
works
did you know that
I hate it
and oh my God
I just keeping this old record that my
mom is in a complete snob who literally
like we we lost our cat because of her
uh I mean we the cat got out of the
house because she keeps leaving doors
open to like the front door of the house
the the freaking uh the screen door on
it doesn't shut and the the door handle
on it on both sides of the door is
messed up like there's literally no
actual through the window oh [ __ ]
wait hold on fix it sorry guys yeah it
just popped out it does it doesn't
matter you're just missing him filming
the same thing yeah really the the
[ __ ] views never matter yeah the door
handle is like it's like barely even
attached to the door like it's been
needing to be replaced your father's
dying of cancer downstairs like years
and years and years I don't even know
when like how long ago it was damaged
that badly on the front door so the
screen door
doesn't shut and they were leaving the
like and the front door itself
um unless you lock it it kind of opens
it doesn't stay shut you have to lock it
so the cat ran away because they were a
little they were not mindful of closing
the screen door properly and not
thinking of Dayton because the patriarch
of the family is dying of cancer
downstairs
right
so basically they keep it unlocked and
it comes out there and they've been
doing that on purpose not even on accent
they've been intentionally doing it so
that people can walk in the house to
um
because Dad's been uh immobile he's been
unable to get up why and people have to
have to come into the house to come
visit him because he can't get up out of
this chair to or you know wherever he is
downstairs he can't get up to get the
door open like
and tell anybody in so they would
intentionally do that and naturally
while that's happening like I guess it
was while I was in the hospital when
they uh that's what she says I overheard
her say that I think it was after he got
back from the hospital anyway whatever I
don't know anyway whatever he's dynaking
he's dying the cancer look the cat got
away I mean I'm gonna keep talking about
me me me me like what a piece of garbage
right the the absolute lack of motion
when he discusses his dad who's dying
yeah and it's not even like you're
discussing like a family member who died
a long time ago you know it's like all
right I can understand you're not
getting as emotional now but like this
is still happening like he's still alive
remember and he he won't be alive later
and that's like the hardest thing to
deal with and it's just not even phasing
him and you know remember when he
thought Dr Phil was going to save him
and now he thinks that Andy warhol's
family is going to take interest in him
and save him that's not a joke
wait what yeah he really believes that
what happened to Christina Ricci well I
mean you know I don't know maybe that
that one fell out but I mean he thinks
that's the person that's going to save
him now what is Andy warhol's family
have to like Dr Phil made sense you
watch him on I don't know you know he
saves people but like
I don't know specifically I just know
that that's
true when you see a [ __ ] a painting
of uh Soup cans and I'll get I'll get
more information I will get more
information on that I promise but we are
trying to get a GoFundMe for for Jerry
going because I mean I really [ __ ]
sucks you know and and to answer the
question because a lot of people ask and
I've asked it is like why did the family
keep putting up with him and not in not
in their defense but for everything
that's been explained to me by people
who are close to the situation is
they're really good people and they
don't they they even when families
[ __ ] up they want to take care of
family even though just so you go know
this even to go fund me
the family the reason we even have one
up right now is because they what I was
told is they're not the type that like
charity or anything like that you know
so that's just how they are it makes
sense especially after everything we
watch it does make sense right so you
know to have somebody like [ __ ] that
yeah it kind of sucks man yeah but at
the same time it's like I get your nice
people but at what point you know you
have to sometimes make a decision like
this is when somebody's pres like this
is the the same thing with drug addicts
you know you can have a functioning
addict in the family but then you can
have an addict that's like literally you
cannot like I've always been kind of a
mess right I've never been a guy yeah I
know it's shocking I don't want to blow
people's mind here and blow your tits
off with this Insider info but I could
be a little crazy sometimes
um would that be a documentary about it
but I've never been I've never had
family members go listen
make sure there's somebody here at the
house with Mike's here okay you know
what I mean like and when you have
somebody like that in the family
sometimes you gotta cut them loose man
you know when they're stealing [ __ ]
people's [ __ ] and like you know stealing
appliances that I asked if I crack it's
like all right man at what point do you
go I like you know we don't want to cut
people out in the streets but we also
you know we need a [ __ ] gas stove in
the house because they're gonna probably
you know be hard to find someday